los ging es nicht mit Fußball sondern
mit Golf das war sozusagen der erste
Angriff die erste Attacke sind
interessante Geschichte eigentlich ein
Krimi was ist da passiert am Ende war es
so dass man sich natürlich in
Saudi-Arabien angeschaut hat in auf
welchen Bereichen können wir überhaupt
reinkommen und als großer Player gleich
auftreten und natürlich funktioniert
Golf ganz großartig es ist hoch
attraktiver fernsehsport es ist etwas
was man natürlich auch eigentlich mal
ganz gut verpflanzen kann es hat einen
großen Konkurrenz gegeben einer zwischen
der PGA also der angestammten
Amerikaner der amerikanischen Tour die
ja auch über viele viele Jahre
traditionell die große Tour war im Golf
und dann hat man eben gesagt da stellen
wir einfach mal eine Konkurrenz Nummer
dagegen sehr schlecht auf 54 Löcher eben
nur drei Mal diese Runde zu spielen
statt vier wie es traditionell bei der
DJI der Fall war und man hat sich über
viele Monate Jahre beträgt es gab quasi
nur die Frage entscheide dich für uns
oder gegen uns es gab spielt
Schauspieler wie Tiger Woods die gesagt
haben wir bleiben auf jeden Fall bei der
PGA es gab andere wie den deutschen
Martin Kaymer die gesagt haben komm wir
gehen mal rüber für viel Geld jetzt hat
man sich plötzlich und für viele Profis
die gesagt haben wir werden nie was mit
den anderen zu tun haben fusioniert das
Entsetzen ist auch groß gerade in der
Golfszene gerade weil natürlich auch
diese neue Tour auf ganz viele
Traditionen einfach gepfiffen hat es gab
viel kirmesmusik es gab andere
Inszenierung also das traditionelle was
es beim Golf gab das hat meine saudiabe
nicht so hochgehalten hat aber da hat
man gesehen es ist erfolgreich man kann
natürlich sehr sehr viel Geld viel
bewegen und sich da auch richtig naja
hineindrängen in so einem Sport Martin
keiner den sie gerade angesprochen haben
der der deutsche Golfprofi Geld ist für
jeden Menschen eine Motivation ich bin
kein Politiker ich bin Profi Golfer
sagen
diese Diskussion haben wir bei Katha
auch geführt wir führen Sie immer dann
wenn Autokratien massiv in den Sport
investieren und die Frage muss ich
glaube ich jeder Profisportler selbst
stellen wie wichtig ist ihm Geld wie
wichtig sind ihm die Traditionen und der
der wie wichtig ist ihm die Identität
seine Sports bei Golf ist es mit
Sicherheit so wie wie Herr Köster auch
sagt saudi-Arabien hat hier eine Nische
gesehen um wirklich weltweit und gerade
auf dem amerikanischen Markt Einfluss
nehmen zu können sich wirtschaftlich zu
diversifizieren und mitreden zu können
mit den großen und dementsprechend auch
mit viel Geld eben Profisportler
geködert ich glaube bezahlt also es gibt
so die die davon sprechen dass für
Michelsen einem der besten Golfsportler
der Welt bis zu 200 Millionen geboten
worden sein sollen also es gibt
astronomische Summen ich glaube bei
Tiger wo stand mal 700 Millionen im Raum
hätte das Angebot ausgeschlagen
dementsprechend wird da auf jeden Fall
gekotzt und nicht gekleckert um im
Umgang für
ein Prämien
spielt wie lange
das ist ja tatsächlich dass das große
Problem ist ist vieles noch gar nicht
sicher die lifttour existiert zwar wird
auch dieses Jahr zu Ende spielen aber
wie es dann weitergeht dass das weiß man
tatsächlich nicht auch diese Einigung
ist das ein Joint Venture ist das eine
neue Unternehmensgründung vieles davon
weiß man nicht in den USA sieht man es
sehr kritisch da gibt's tatsächlich
verschiedene Gerichtsverhandlungen und
Anhörungen und dementsprechend haben
sich da Männer die die Macht haben auf
der einen Seite eben die wichtigen
Männer der PGA auf der anderen Seite ein
ganz eine ganz wichtige Figur aus
Saudi-Arabien ja sehr Roman
zusammengesetzt
ist der Chef des Public Investments also
das saudischen Entwicklungsfonds an
dessen Spitze Mohammed Bensheim an der
Kronprinz selbst steht dass der Mann der
mir hier im Hintergrund sehen ja das ist
der Mann der den wir da sehen ähm er ist
nicht nur der Chef von des pff also der
Architekt der Investitionen sondern er
ist zum Beispiel auch der starke Mann
bei Newcastle United das übernommen
wurde vom public Investmentfonds er ist
auch der Chef von Saudi arabo und
dementsprechend ein ganz wichtiger und
Strippenzieher innerhalb der saudischen
Politik und gerade um das kurz zu klären
Saudi Aramco ist die die die die
Ölgesellschaft das wertvollste
Unternehmen der Welt absolut im letztes
Jahr wie viel Gewinn gemacht was hat das
151 Milliarden sowas in der Art ähm
eines der größten also der wichtigste
glaube das beste Geschäftsjahr auch in
der in der Geschichte von Saudi arabo
und das ist natürlich das Tafel Silber
Saudi Arabiens die Ölproduktion
generiert nach wie vor die große
Mehrheit der Staatseinnahmen darauf
basiert auch jetzt diese ganze
Investitionspolitik im Sport und den
anderen Bereichen weil man das Erdöl
nutzt um sich dann langfristig vom Erdöl
unabhängiger zu machen weil wir gerade
sehen stimmt ist das Donald Trump auch
Golfplätze in Saudi Arabien betreibt ja
also diese Beziehung zwischen Donald
Trump und Saudi Arabien ist ja eh eine
ganz spezielle ja in der Tat erklärt
sich jetzt aber noch mal besser wenn man
so ja es geht ja nicht nur um Gold es
geht natürlich um knallharte Politik
wenn sie zurück erinnern Donald Trump
hat seine erste Auslandsreise nachdem er
als Präsident gewählt wurde nach Saudi
getätigt und das nicht nur weil er diese
Audios gerne mag sondern auch weil es
darum ging tatsächlich eine enge
politische und wirtschaftliche
Partnerschaft zu festigen saudi-Arabien
hat sich sehr viel von Donald Trump
erhofft damals auch die Unterstützung in
politischen Fragen Sicherheit Garantien
Rüstungslieferungen etc und diese
Verbindung jetzt durch den Golf ist
deswegen auch unter diesem vor diesem
Hintergrund zu sehen
Fußball welche Rolle spielt dieser Mann
im Fußball Newcastle United haben sie
gerade angesprochen was wir haben
wann wann war das als sie das übernommen
haben
Newcastle November 2022 genau wir haben
kurz davor mit einem Kamerateam damals
dort oben auf der Ecke und wenn man das
so erlebt hat wie wie verzweifelt da die
Situation teilweise auch ist wie hoch
die Arbeitslosigkeit ist wie sehr
Menschen sich nach ein bisschen
Ablenkung Sehnen und sie auch brauchen
dann versteht man natürlich das so ein
großer Investor dann an dem Punkt
einfach willkommen
hinschaut die Reaktion der Fans waren ja
größtenteils positiv das kann natürlich
auch positiv überrascht und ich glaube
das ist im englischen Fußballer
mittlerweile gegangen und gäbe ist das
ausländische Investoren sich Einkaufen
wir haben Mensch dass der City wo die
Emirate drin sind die haben viele viele
andere die Gläser Brüder bei Manchester
United etc das heißt dass man viel mehr
dran gewöhnt als bei uns dazu kommt noch
eins Saudi Arabien hat sich Newcastle ja
auch aus strategischen Gründen
ausgesucht man wie sie schon gesagt
haben hohe Arbeitslosigkeit gleichzeitig
aber auch geografisch interessant
gelegen
Meereszugang Saudi-Arabien versucht sich
auch als maritimer Player in der
Logistik stärker zu positionieren möchte
deswegen auch in Newcastle investieren
erneuerbare Energien sollen in dem
Bereich angesiedelt werden in England
das ist für Saudi Arabien auch
interessant und damit folgt man dem
Vorbild von Manchester oder dem Vorbild
von Katha bei PSG und dem Vorbild von
den Emiraten bei Manchester City die im
Jahre haben viele Immobilien in
Manchester gekauft die die Kataris haben
in Paris und in Frankreich grundsätzlich
diese Partnerschaft diese Übernahme von
PSG genutzt um auch politischen und
wirtschaftlichen Einfluss zu nehmen und
das ist eben auch der Treiber hinter
dieser Sportpolitik Saudi Arabiens neue
Märkte zu erobern und sich auch ein
gewisser Art und Weise wirtschaftlich
und ersetzt sich zu machen und das heißt
es gibt eine langfristigen Plan ja nicht
einfach mal eben eine Laune Köster dass
jemand einfach sich mal Ronaldo gönnt
sondern gibt es einen langen Plan die
die arabische die saudische Fußball Liga
wie muss man sich das vorstellen 16
Clubs habe ich mir sagen lassen ja vor
allen Dingen ist es eine Liga wenn man
glaube ich nicht verwechseln kann man
denkt dann aber das ist das gleiche wie
ein Katar einfach hochgezogen und da
kommen keine Zuschauer fakt ist dass der
größte Club dort 39.000 Zuschauer im
Schnitt hat also das ist jetzt nicht
Bundesliga aber das ist auf einem ganz
gehobenen mittleren europäischen Niveau
Niveau bei einer Bevölkerung von
ungefähr glaube ich 35 Millionen ne ne
große Begeisterung zu geben ja also es
gibt seit den 70er Jahren diese polik
man hat durchaus eine gewisse
fußballtrition aber klar ist natürlich
das bisher sieht man mal von ein paar
Pokal ab das ist natürlich mit dem
europäischen Niveau überhaupt nicht zu
vergleichen und natürlich hat man einen
Masterplan dass man sagt man möchte in
den nächsten Jahren irgendwie
konkurrenzfähig werden es gab ja sogar
schon Schlagzeilen dass man sich
bewerben möchte um ein Ticket in der
Europa in der europäischen Champions
League eine Art Wildcard dass man eben
dann als saudisches Team damit spielt
und Empörung zurückgewiesen wurde
zurückgewiesen bis man da sagen ja jetzt
lass uns noch mal nachdenken reden
dass dann mit nee auch weil man wem
gehören diese Vereine ich habe mir sagen
es gibt vier top Clubs
wem gehören die wer besitzt die also
vier Talk Clubs sind ja alle von diesem
Fonds der viele viele Milliarden schwer
ist aufgezeichnet den selben Besitzer ja
das wäre so wie wenn man hier in
Deutschland beispielsweise RB Leipzig
hätten die einfach vier Teams in der
Bundesliga ins Rennen schicken würden
und sagen hey das ist ein spannender
Wettbewerb dabei sind das einfach nur
unterschiedliche Filialen wie wie
Filialen von Media Markt oder von Saturn
von wem auch immer also da kann von
ordentlichen geordneten sportlichen
Wettbewerb also auch von
unterschiedlichen Vereinen von
Mitgliedern Mitbestimmung von Fan
überhaupt gar keine Rolle sein aber
natürlich muss man sich wahrscheinlich
in irgendeiner Weise auch lösen davon
dass man alle westlichen Formen auf
dieses System drauf tropft klar ist eben
auch es gibt eine gewisse Fußballkultur
aber klar ist eben auch was da gerade
läuft das ist Kirmes das ist große
Fußballcamp ist aber das hat mit dem was
wir in Europa kennenzulernen sie
Verständnis für diese Spieler die das
machen ganz neutral gefragt also wenn es
nur darum geht nimmst du die Kohle oder
ich wahrscheinlich würde jeder irgendwie
prinzipiell immer bei einem so
lukrativen Jobangebot erstmal zögern
klar ist aber auch warum sind diese
Leute eigentlich Sportler geworden was
treibt die an mich wieder das ehrlich
gesagt an wenn man gerade ältere
Sportler hat also die vielleicht 31 32
sind die schon so unendlich viel Geld in
ihrem Leben das ist die Entscheidung
unendlich viel Geld Cristiano Ronaldo
ist wahrscheinlich Milliardär oder er
ist Milliardär und er sagt trotzdem hey
ich nehme das noch mal mit und es ist
mir völlig egal was für eine Liga ich
spiele was das mit meinem Ruf macht ob
das meine Integrität als Sportler und
irgendein angeht ich nehme das Geld
einfach mit und es ist das gleiche bei
Neymar es ist jetzt weil was ist mit
Jordan Henderson John Anderson ist für
mich eines der tragischen Beispiele
einer der in seinen Liverpool zeigten
ein Hoch geachteter Profi war der sich
extrem für die btq-rechte eingesetzt hat
einer der auch für Minderheiten in Auge
hatte der sich immer wieder durch kluge
Äußerung in die Schlagzeilen gespielt
hat und dann stellt man fest der geht
einfach er hat wahnsinnig viel Kohle
geboten bekommen und eiert jetzt rum hat
z.B auch zugelassen dass er auf einem
Bild einem Vorstellungsbild auf dem er
zu sehen war bei seinem neuen clockt
dass das schwarz-weiß eingeblendet wurde
damit man die regenbogenbinde an seinem
erzieht naja das sind Absurditäten die
man eben macht wenn man unfassbar viel
Geld nimmt und in der Schuld dieser
Auftraggeber dieser neuen Vereine ist
über welche Summen sprechen wir da wir
reden über in seinem Fall also bei
Jordan Henderson sind es kolportierte 80
Millionen bei im Jahr bei Neymar sind es
auch es sind ja immer so drei
Jahresverträge die abgeschlossen werden
damit ich nach einem Jahr nicht gleich
wieder abhauen reden wir immer von Range
von 80 bis 120 Millionen Euro liegt die
kassieren soll und das ist natürlich
absolut pro Jahr pro Jahr die
ausgeschüttet werden weil natürlich
diese großen Stars die Zugpferde sein
sollen für diese Liga man kann es
natürlich auch noch Mittelklasse Spieler
aus der Bundesliga aus der Serie oder
ist der ersten Liga in Spanien
verpflichten aber das bringt dann halt
nicht wer hat es nicht gemacht
ein paar haben es nicht gemacht zum
Beispiel mbappé hatte er auch eine
unmoralisches Angebot aber der ist noch
zu jung zu ehrgeizig der weiß natürlich
auch wenn ich bei PSD spiele habe ich
meine Chance die Champions League zu
gewinnen in Saudi-Arabien halte ich dann
möglicherweise mal nationalen Pokal hoch
das kann mich jetzt nicht so reizen aber
klar ist eben auch wer weiß was mit 30
mit 31 und 32 ist dann wird vielleicht
auch eher dem Ruf Erliegen und ich
glaube eben diese Absurdität dieser so
das verändert den Blick vieler Leute die
sagen wenn es alle machen mache ich auch
und ich glaube je mehr von diesem
jüngeren Profis auch wechseln zu desto
mehr wird es auch egal sein
die die das machen gibt auch Trainer
Salzburg ja und Steven beispielsweise
von dem man immer gedacht hat der wird
bald einen großen europäischen Club
übernehmen war bei den Rangers war bei
der ersten Villa dort rausgeflogen und
ist jetzt zack in Saudi Arabien verdient
unfassbar viel Geld und Eier
italienische national Trainer hat gesagt
hätte der ist integer der ist jemand der
weiß worum es eigentlich im Sport geht
gut der hat vor drei Millionen verdient
jetzt kriegt der 25
ist ein Unterschied aber gab es das fand
ich sehr interessant gab es in Italien
eine riesige Debatte darüber und die
Moment habe ich das Gefühl Italien ist
für Mancini gerade kein guter Ort da
sollte dort nicht unbedingt gesehen
werden ja die Italiener das wirklich
übel nehmen und ich fand es interessant
dass die Debatte sozusagen weniger eine
moralische Debatte war um die Frage ist
es jetzt Saudi-Arabien sondern es ging
eigentlich mehr um das Gefühl unabhängig
davon jetzt wer es ist ihr seid
Vorbilder warum warum warum folgt dir
nur noch dem Ruf des Goldes das war das
Thema ich glaube dass jetzt so ganz ganz
offenkundig geworden ist was eigentlich
immer schon so war also natürlich der
Sport ist unendlich versaut durchs Geld
seit vielen vielen Jahren und wir haben
überall gesehen wer zahlt bekommt
eigentlich seinen Willen und wenn noch
viel mehr Zeit kommt auch die tollsten
Spieler wir haben das vor ein paar
Jahren auch mit China erlebt die auch
mal mit richtig viel Geld in den Markt
reinmarschiert sind wir sehen natürlich
ManCity ist eigentlich ein plastik-club
der sogar die fanfahnen seine an
digitalisieren und über Bildschirme in
seinem Stadion ausspielen lässt trotzdem
die gewinnen die Champions League sind
in irgendeiner Weise beliebt weil er
earling Holland da spielt weil andere
große Starter spielen also wer zahlt
bestimmt eigentlich auch die Musik klar
ist aber auch in solchen Fällen in denen
es eigentlich keinen anderen Grund gibt
als das Geld nach Saudi-Arabien zu
wechseln ist das natürlich wie ein
schlaglich die Leute sehen hey guck mal
der Kaiser hat keine Kleider an äh den
den wir so verehrt haben der gucken nur
auf die Kohle weil wir gerade sehen
Christian Ronaldo sie sagen da geht's
nur ums Geld das würde ich stark
bezweifeln also Cristiano Ronaldo sagt
das ganz ganz anders vielleicht können
wir einmal ganz kurz reinhören eine sehr
sehr schöne Begründung warum ist jetzt
ausgerechnet Saudi Arabien sein musste
hör mal kurz rein
meine Arbeit in Europa ist getan ich
habe alles gewonnen ich habe in den
wichtigsten Vereinen gespielt und für
mich ist das jetzt eine neue
Herausforderung in Asien
für mich ist das eine tolle Gelegenheit
nicht nur im Fußball sondern auch die
Mentalität der jungen Generationen zu
formen
ich habe mich für diesen Verein
entschieden für die Möglichkeit nicht
nur für den Fußball sondern auch dieses
großartige Land mit weiter zu entwickeln
Herausforderung ich weiß was ich will
und ich weiß auch was ich nicht will
für mich ist es eine gute Chance zu
verändern zu helfen mit meinem Wissen
und meiner Erfahrung
in vielen wichtigen Punkten zu helfen
auch bezüglich des Frauenfußballs viele
wissen das nicht aber Elena hat auch
einen frauenfußballteam und ich möchte
eine neue Perspektive zeigen vom Land
und vom Fußball die Sicht von allen
zeigen
deshalb habe ich diese Möglichkeit
wahrgenommen
gott sei Dank hat der Ton dann versagt
ich bin zwischendurch muss ich sagen
ja vier Minuten Begründung und nichts
davon wird glaubwürdig ich behaupte mal
oder vielleicht ist natürlich auch
ungerecht ihm gegenüber ich behaupte mal
dass er von dem Club zu dem er da
gewechselt ist vor dem ersten Angebot
noch nie was gehört hat oder sehr sehr
sporadisch nur was gehört hat natürlich
kann er das alles behaupten aber klar
ist einfach er ist mit Geld zugeworfen
worden natürlich kann auch immer
behaupten dass seine Arbeit in Europa
getan ist das hat er von einem Jahr noch
anders gesehen und klar ist eben auch er
hat ganz ganz viel jetzt natürlich nicht
mehr was er früher hatte nämlich
Aufmerksamkeit also ich glaube dass die
internationale Sichtbarkeit von
Cristiano Ronaldo rapide abgenommen hat
einfach aber davon hatte er reichlich ne
davon hatte er reichlich aber klar ist
eben auch dass er jetzt sagt das ist
eine ganz neue Herausforderung und jetzt
starte ich noch mal richtig durch das
würde ich stark bezweifeln und wenn wir
sozusagen in der Logik bleiben dass es
ein immer weniger um den Club geht
sondern vielmehr um einzelne Superstars
wie Cristiano Ronaldo die Kinder die
Jugendlichen die folgen ihm plötzlich
schau noch Kinder hierzulande arabische
Fußball Liga ja und ich glaube das ist
tatsächlich auch eines der wichtigsten
Kalküle die saudi-Arabien hat ich kann
Cristiano Ronaldo ich kenne ihn nicht
ich kann das nicht beurteilen aber
selbstverständlich klingt das klingt das
sehr floskelig was er sagen nein aber so
dass er sich immer sehr für
Frauenfußball angesetzt hat das wissen
wir ja insofern aber Perspektive auch
mit Menschen sprechen die in
Saudi-Arabien tatsächlich ähm jetzt dort
auch den Fußball verfolgen geht es auch
darum tatsächlich Vorbilder zu schaffen
Saudi Arabien hat eine Gesellschaft die
sehr junge ist 60% sind unter 30 wir
haben eine riesen Problem anziehen
Krankheiten ja sind 20% haben Diabetes
50% sind übergewichtig in Saudi Arabien
ist es ein Muss dass viele Menschen
Sport treiben und dieses Kalkül steckt
in gewisser Art und Weise auch hinter
diesen Investitionen mit Vorbildern wie
Christiane Ronaldo Menschen zum Sport
treiben zu bringen das mag jetzt das ist
mit Sicherheit nicht der einzige Grund
der wichtigste Grund aber es ist einer
die Gesellschaft in Saudi-Arabien hat
große Herausforderungen und man möchte
Jobs schaffen in der Sportindustrie man
hat immer noch knapp 20%
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit in Saudi-Arabien
das wissen wir hier nicht aber das darf
man auch nicht unberücksichtigt lassen
deswegen ist diese Strategie mit
Cristiano Ronaldo und anderen Stars
tatsächlich auch Vorbilder als eine Land
zu holen aus saudischer Perspektive
sinnvoll und es wird von den Menschen
vor Ort angenommen Sie haben die sie
haben die Zuschauerzahlen angesprochen
natürlich geht es darum Marken zu
schaffen Nation Branding zu betreiben
und die Social Media Follower Zahlen der
Club der Clubs wie anders sie sind
rapide gestiegen weil wir sie heute hier
haben also einmal ganz kurzen kleiner
Exkurs wirklich in dieses Land und hat
gesagt 35 Millionen Einwohner da gibt es
diesen Staatsform der unendlich viel
Geld hat und man denkt
ist für alle bestens gesorgt ist es aber
nicht ist ein Land das gerade in einer
gewaltigen Transformation steckt dass
einen schwierigen Ruf loszuwerden hat
muss man sich nur mal kurz in Erinnerung
rufen ist nicht lange her ja 15 der 19
Attentäter vom 11 September waren Saudis
und und damit war auch das imagegesetz
dann kommt der Mord an khogi und vieles
vieles andere dann kommt dieses Bild
sozusagen wir wir machen mit den
Ölpreisen was immer wir wollen und und
wir erpressen euch wann immer es gerade
passt also kein guter Ruf aber jetzt ist
doch dort auch glaube ich jedem klar
dieses Öl Zeitalter geht zu Ende auch
wenn es gerade fantastisch läuft
und dann die Frage was machst du mit 20
Prozent arbeitslosen Jugendlichen sie
sagten irgendwo in einem Interview uns
ist das nicht so klar junge Leute heute
in Saudi-Arabien die Arbeiten richtig
richtig hart anders als ihre Eltern zum
Teil ja Saudi arabisch da genau Saudi
Arabien ist eines der faszinierendsten
und widersprüchlichsten Länder in der
Region mindestens ich beschäftige mich
mit dem Land seit 15 Jahren jetzt bin
seit 2008 das erste Mal da gewesen und
das Land ist ein vollkommen anderes die
Menschen sind vollkommen anders es gibt
tatsächlich große große
Herausforderungen sie haben es gerade
angesprochen junge Menschen leben nicht
mehr in diesen paradiesischen Zeiten wie
ihre Eltern oder Großeltern oder das Öl
tatsächlich dafür gesorgt hat dass man
Steuerfreiheit hatte dass man den Job im
öffentlichen Dienst hatte dass man frei
Gesundheitsversorgung hatte und so
weiter die Zeiten sind vorbei wir haben
15 % Mehrwertsteuer mittlerweile in
Saudi Arabien das wäre vor 10 15 Jahren
undenkbar gewesen Menschen sind
arbeitslos Menschen müssen sehr hart für
ihren Lebensunterhalt kämpfen es gibt
keine Jobs mehr im öffentlichen Sektor
es gibt wohnungsmang es gibt tatsächlich
das Problem dass viele junge Menschen
Frauen die Männer sich ihre Ehe nicht
mehr leisten können die Hochzeit nicht
mehr ausrichten können das heißt im
Gegensatz zu Cutter wo wir wirklich
übermäßigen Rechnungen haben ist
Saudi-Arabien ein Land in dem die
sozialen Gefälle wirklich massiv sind
wir haben unfassbar viel Reichtum bei
einer relativ kleinen Gruppe von
Menschen und wir haben aber auch
wirklich eine breite Mittelschicht die
mittlerweile auch gut im Ausland
studiert und ausgebildet wurde jetzt
zurückkommt und tatsächlich in einer
anderen Welt groß geworden ist und viele
dieser Menschen sagen Sport Tourismus
Kultur uns hat das gefehlt wir wollen
ausbrechen aus dieser auf dieser
verkrusteten konservativen Welt in der
wir früher gelebt haben in der unsere
Eltern gelebt haben wollen teilhaben und
müssen dafür auch Opfer bringen und ich
glaube das ist etwas was ein
Saudi-Arabien tatsächlich momentan
abläuft und das ist auch der große
Balanceakt den der Staat den der
Kronprinz verfolgen und erfolgreich
bestreiten musste denn viel Geld in
Fußballer zu investieren kann für eine
gewisse Euphorie morgen kann aber auch
irgendwann zu finanzieren wie kommt das
denn an bei einer Bevölkerung die immer
mehr kämpft momentan noch sehr gut
momentan also es gibt natürlich keine
Umfragen deswegen sind das auch von mir
anekdotische Erzählung aber viele
Menschen finden das gut einfach weil man
jetzt auch die Möglichkeit hat ins
Stadien zu gehen die Möglichkeit hat
selbst Sport zu treiben viele Frauen die
Möglichkeit haben zu arbeiten Auto zu
fahren etc das gab es bis vor einigen
Jahren nicht aber auf der anderen Seite
gibt es glaube ich schon auch den Wunsch
nachhaltig was für das eigene Leben zu
tun und auch Verbesserungen zu sehen und
diese Verbesserung müssen kommen und
wenn diese Rendite nicht ausgezahlt wird
kann ich mir vorstellen dass es auch
zunehmen Kritik die Geschwindigkeit
dieser Transformation ist zum Teil
wirklich atemberaubend wenn man sich
auch Bauprojekte gigantomanische Zeit
hier drüber gesprochen
und andere Dinge anschauen eine Frau
hier mal in der Sendung vor vielen
Jahren die echte Schwierigkeiten kriegte
weil Sie Auto fahren wollte
jüngst las ich dass es mittlerweile
prozentual in Saudi-Arabien mehr Mädchen
die Frauen gibt die
IT studieren als in Deutschland anteilig
kann das sein ja das kann gut sein also
es ist schon lange lange Jahre so dass
mehr Frauen die Universität abschließen
als Männer es ist lange lange Jahre
schon so dass die Frauen besser
ausgebildet sind als die Männer und
dementsprechend war diese Lockerung
gerade auch was die Rechte für Frauen
angeht ja nicht nur gut Menschen tun
sondern da ging es um knallharte
wirtschaftliche Interessen da ging es
darum Frauen in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren und deren human Kapital
nicht zu verschwenden weil Saudi Arabien
sich eben aus dem Öl Zeitalter
verabschieden muss und dementsprechend
eine neue Branche investieren muss und
dafür braucht man die Frauen und das
passiert sind
Rettich noch mal der kurz vor seinem
Antrieb als neuer DFB Geschäftsführer
sagte mir ist das alles so zu wieder
wissen Sie was ich lieber verfolgen
würde wenn jemand in Deutschland einen
Jamaika organisieren würde
wie kommt sowas an den Saudi
also ich habe mit niemandem
Saudi-Arabien über diesen Vorschlag
gesprochen aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass das natürlich sehr
schlecht ankommt gerade weil man in
Saudi-Arabien mittlerweile auch ein
gewisses Selbstbewusstsein an den Tag
legt man ist ja nicht nur im Sport sehr
aktiv man positioniert sich in einer
multipolaren Welt auch als politische
Akteur man versucht zwischen den
einzelnen Polen USA und China hin und
her zu lavieren man versucht sich als
Vermittler zu positionieren und
dementsprechend werden solche Äußerungen
in Saudi Arabien tatsächlich als ja
zumindest mal als fehlendes Verständnis
aber auch als Doppelmoral und Heuchlerei
wahrgenommen wie finden Sie diesen
Vorschlag
ob man Pokal nach ihm benennt es gibt
natürlich Provokation ganz viele andere
nach denen man das sicherlich auch noch
benennen könnte die ist ebenfalls
verdient hätten klar ist aber auch dass
dieses nonchanlante drüber hinweggehen
dass wir natürlich jetzt auch gerade von
vielen Sportlern Erleben von vielen die
versuchen zu rechtfertigen dass da jetzt
eben einfach viel Geld rein geschoben
wird durch diese Liga nicht akzeptabel
klar ist für mich dass jeder Sportler
sich nur mal speziell diese Frage
stellen muss gehöre ich dahin folge ich
jetzt quasi dem Lockruf des Geldes oder
ist mir Integrität irgendwie noch was
wert habe ich möglicherweise mit den
Werten die ich immer versuche zu
transportieren die mich auch am Sportler
werden lassen ob die möglicherweise
irgendwann auch dazu führen sagen die
extra Millionen brauche ich jetzt nicht
mehr auf der anderen Seite kommt
wahrscheinlich also da gehen Leute hin
und kopieren einfach das was wir ihnen
vorgemacht haben was wir aufgebaut haben
unser eigenes System und dann beschweren
uns darüber dass sie uns mit unserem
System weil sie es noch ein bisschen
weiter getrieben haben am Ende dann
platt machen aber was ist das für System
das wir dass die kopieren das ist ein
System was wo Kommerzialisierung Fußball
eine Rolle spielt wir haben ja vorhin
auch Geld
ich würde aber mal sagen es gibt ja am
Anfang erst einmal ein System das heißt
erstmal Volkssport Fußball das damit
Geld gemacht wird ist ein zweiter
Schritt der erste Schritt ist hier
erstmal wir haben die größte
Alltagskultur Deutschlands
beispielsweise wir haben jedes
Wochenende 100.000 die ins Stadion gehen
es ist erstmal Sport es ist Begeisterung
im Stadion und ich bin noch ein bisschen
vorsichtig damit zu sagen Geld ist das
System nee ich würde sagen fußball ist
das System fußball ist erstmal Sport
Begeisterung Nähe zwischen Akteuren und
Zuschauern fußball ist eine unglaublich
große wirkmächtige Kultur hier in
Deutschland und haben das zweite System
Geld und natürlich kann man jetzt sagen
das ist auch ein System das wird mächtig
ist aber erstmal würde ich sagen
das prinzipielle System ist erstmal
Fußball und das wird nicht so einfach
kopiert in Saudi-Arabien ja stimme ich
Ihnen zu aber ich glaube dass man in
Saudi-Arabien momentan eben die Ansicht
hat so wie man das in Katar auch gesehen
hat
dass man dort eine Alternative schaffen
möchte zu dem Monopol das Europa auf den
Fußball besitzt und auch in Anspruch
nimmt und diese Stimme außerhalb Europas
tatsächlich auch Menschen ein Angebot im
Fußball zu machen dass sie sonst nicht
wahrnehmen können die wird glaube ich
stärker und die passt sehr gut rein in
dieses von mir vorher schon
angesprochene Selbstbewusstsein in Saudi
Arabien möchte eine Alternative bieten
und dementsprechend kopiert man
sozusagen die Mechanismen die im
professionellen Fußball existieren aber
welches Monopol ist das ist ein
wahrgenommenes Monopol in Saudi Arabien
dass man sagt in Europa hat man den an
den Anspruch den Fußball für sich zu
besitzen und wenn jemand wie Saudi
Arabien oder Kata quasi als neuer als
new kid in town jetzt da versucht den
Laden aufzumischen dann wird das erstmal
abgelehnt weil das eben nicht der
Fußball ist den man in Europa gerne
hätte das ist das ist das Argument das
ist das narrativ dass man in
Saudi-Arabien sehr stark spielt übrigens
nicht nur im Sport sondern auch in der
Politik und ich glaube diese dieses
gewachsene Selbstbewusstsein das muss
man nicht gut finden gar keine Frage man
muss es aber ernst nehmen weil es
tatsächlich glaube ich auch viel darüber
aussagt wie sich Geopolitik derzeit
entwickelt und das Spiel Sport einfach
mit rein das ist Teil dieses
Gesamtprozesses wie sich die Welt
derzeit positioniert und da will ein
Land wie Saudi Arabien mehr Mitsprache
recht haben und sagt eben ihr habt den
Fußball nicht gepachtet er gehört euch
nicht wir wollen mitspielen und
dementsprechend jammert nicht so laut
rum das ist das ist das was man in Saudi
Arabien tatsächlich der denkt